you were watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video just
10 years ago nobody would have ever
thought electric vehicles would be in
mass production yet alone changed the
auto industry today most car
manufacturers are thinking about
all-electric vehicles Volvo is have been
saying that they made ditched diesel
cars altogether and switch to hybrid and
electric cars what was once the pipe
dream and impractical is now reality in
the auto industry but now in the latter
part of the 2010s the electric
revolution is taken to the skies battery
tech is just getting good enough to
allow several companies to roll out
their fully electric aircraft into
production in this quick video we'll
take a look at the state of the art of
six wing electric aircraft earlier the
TR the German firm Simmons just
demonstrated a powerful electric
aircraft that broke two old records the
first was a speed record it was the
fastest electric aircraft flying at a
straight-line speed of 340 kilometers
now it also breaks a climbing record
rising from the ground to 3 kilometers
in just over 4 minutes it was also the
first electric aircraft to air tow the
aircraft and extra 330 le was able to do
this thanks to a new generation of
electric motors from Simmons weighing
just 50 kilograms the motor can produce
260 kilowatts about five times the power
of comparable aircraft engines or about
as much output as the original Tesla
Model S
Simmons plans to use this aircraft as a
testbed for developing more in the
future another company people strong
from Slovenia if getting ready to ship
their fully electric light aircraft the
Alpha electrode the Alpha electro will
be used for flight training purposes and
takes 45 minutes to fully charge the
aircraft cuts overall costs of flight
training by 70% from fuel savings and
the learning process is exactly the same
as its petrol counterparts interestingly
every tenth of a second the system on
the aircraft checks the batteries
monitoring their voltage and looking out
for any faults it can electronically
disconnect parts of the battery if the
system predicts a fault upon landing the
propeller turns into a generator
recharging about five percent of the
battery yet another company Aero
Electric is launching another
all-electric plane called the sunflower
it has the same idea of reducing the
cost of flight training this is really a
history-making event Aero electric
aircraft corporation has just unveiled a
prototype of its new all-electric Sun
flyer plane which could open up the
skies to many more pilots by using
electricity they claim that the price
goes down from $45 per flight hour down
to $1.00 per flight hour a real quantum
leap I think this use case makes the
most sense for all electric air travel
small planes one to two passengers and
short trips from 30 minutes to 1.5 hours
it would be good for scenic aerial tours
short charter flights or pilot training
so what are the advantages and
disadvantages of electric propulsion
well the advantages are as follows it's
quieter mechanically more efficient and
doesn't have any direct emissions the
disadvantages is the battery the
bottleneck really is with the battery
energy density it's just not good enough
yet for long distance flight in addition
to this with traditional aircraft the
more fuel you burn the light of the
craft gets but with electric aircraft
the batteries are essentially dead
weight this is where hybrid systems come
into play more so than cars hybrid
planes seem to be the sweet spot for air
travel they can be used for medium
distances flying for about two to four
hours
Airbus is working on a hybrid plane to
go into production by 2030
this comes after successfully testing
their own fully electric aircraft dubbed
the efan a project that ran from 2014 to
last month during its testing the efan
was claimed to be the first electric
plane to cross the English Channel with
help from Simmons both to the straw and
Airbus are in the work for creating
hybrid motors but the hybrid motor from
Pipistrel is already in testing phases
and makes about 200 kilowatts so in
conclusion electric aircraft have been
in the experimental stages for many
decades but were woefully underpowered
and largely have the same issues as
electric cars before Tesla got the ball
rolling
now practical electric aircraft are
right around the corner in the next year
or two they'll be fully in service but
only for short-range low passenger
volume situations but it seems like
hybrids are far off and this could open
the door to low emission mid-range
flights with the benefits of both an
electric motor and traditional power and
with that that wraps up the video this
was just a quick look at the state of
the art of electric fixed-wing aircraft
thanks for watching this is going to go
you've been watching cold fusion if you
just stumbled across this channel feel
free to subscribe and I'll catch you
again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one cold fusion
if you're thinking
[Music]
you
you
[Music]